cover me in sunshine
the kids will be joining you on tour
Willow has a job on this tour right
she has a job I mean like a chore is a
job she helps with the outfits she can
work a bedazzler and mostly she just
climbs on things and then gets paid for
not paying attention yeah have you two
finalized her rate we have we're going
off of minimum wage okay that's fair but
she doesn't want to pay taxes because
it's not for real so trying to teach her
if she wants to know the real world then
I'm also teaching her how to negotiate
for herself
we're working on it
again teacher mother wife Grammy winner
pink is a superwoman literally
especially after she underwent hip
surgery and double disc replacement in
her neck in 2021 and recently lost 36
pounds of pandemic weight The Bionic
Woman now how are you feeling I feel
like a two dollar bill so she's ready to
go back on the road huh
I'm strong I'm not sure I'm I'm rare but
I might be out of print I
I am stronger than I've ever been in my
life and also I hurt
all the time
you also have two little ones to chase
around yes which that's the fun part
yeah but I can do more push-ups than
anybody what has the recovery been like
and you know what was it like to kind of
relinquish some control during that time
too will you do that as a mom when you
give birth I've given birth twice and
it's it's wild to watch your body
perform a miracle and also then to to
gain your resilience back and it makes
your it makes your body weak for a time
but it makes the rest of you stronger
right and just like an injury I mean
it's how you put yourself back together
yeah afterwards that is the most
important lesson of all of it it must be
nice to have such a amazing support
system like Carrie too though and those
lower you know those darker moments and
also when you're here is a support
system I mean what did you say Sarah
doesn't even know where I am where I am
right he does it
on a recovery he's like you're playing
tennis today why I'm like dude I can't
uh he is a fantastic nurse is he because
he's been injured so much of his life he
is so good he would bring me after my
hip surgery I would crutch and I've
never been incapacitated like this I've
never it's never happened before and
it's humbling and I would be on a bench
in the shower like three days in just
deep deep deep dark depression and
Carrie's bringing me coffee and handing
it to me in the shower and I'm just
sitting there crying about my problems
drinking my coffee water yeah he's a
great nurse I mean that's incredible a
weird story no no it makes sense you
know what that is that's 17 years of
marriage right there so that's 17 years
of marriage I mean we would all be so
lucky to find someone like you he is
pretty
was it a trip to realize that you guys
have been married 17 years like the way
we kind of just Giggle and high five
each other we're not sure which one of
us deserves the trophy you both do I
think it's me why do you think that I
think I deserve the truth why do you
think that because I'm awesome you are
awesome I'm not hard to love
[Music]
pink just released her ninth studio
album trustful it's deeply personal and
filled with reflection so what did you
learn about yourself during the process
of making trust fall because I know you
have said it's one of your most
beautiful and honest records today
yeah and that's a big statement because
I'm always very very open our generation
this generation has ever been through a
huge thing and I feel like the pandemic
was that huge thing for us
and I think
going having the Rogue pulled out from
under you that way losing a parent my
dad passed away in August of 21
. it just distills things down and it
really reminds you of what actually
matters
[Music]
[Applause]
and talk about the weather when you wake
up and all you care about is I just want
to see my kids be okay I just want to be
around long enough to see my kids be
okay
um
and anything I do from here on out has
to matter it has to be important and
that's what this album is to me it's
like it has to matter I was walking in
here right now and a girl came up to me
and said I just wanted to tell you that
turbulence saved my friend's life
and that song came out two weeks ago
literally and that's why you do it it's
like oh okay it's all fun and games and
I look like Mighty Mouse but that's an
important thing that that happened
and I love that I live for that that's
why you keep doing what you're doing
it's not to chase a character yeah yeah
I love the connection people are like
man that song healed me and I'm like
yeah but being at a concert with you and
watching you get healed healed me so
it's just it's a reciprocal love affair
oh good shot good shot that's also why
the Grammy winner is taking part in the
19th annual desert smash celebrity
tennis event to pay it forward and help
raise money for the plane for change
Foundation we did a little warm-up on
the court but somehow I just ended up
being her ball boy get lower are we
dancing
are we twerking what's happening no just
stay low okay okay you stay there get
comfortable
do you have any pets I don't have any
pets no have you ever seen a dog run for
a ball at a dog park yes okay do that
channel that okay I'm the puppy dog got
it I'm already panting like once
[Applause]
drop a sweat sweat do I look like a good
tennis player you really do thank you I
hear that you are though yeah you heard
wrong really yeah well we know we're
gonna fake it till we make it that's why
I wore bright colors to distract listen
I'm channeling you okay because you are
so Fearless I mean you rock out on a
stage now you're rocking out on this
tent is poor but I'm terrified are you
really I'm parasited
I'm terrasided I know this is also part
of your workout routine though so you
have probably better skills than I do I
think going into it at least I've
started playing tennis two years ago
okay and I'm now a sponsored athlete as
of today because I got a free tennis
racket there you go I love it come
through well uh how special is it to be
here I love doing something that you
enjoy and making it about creating
change in the world that's why I write
songs and sing and perform and have the
group that I tour with Playing for
Change is amazing it's about music it's
bringing music to kids that don't have
it
Instruments music theory which for me
I'd be like I can't let's go back to
singing but it's just it's an incredible
thing and I get to play with dimitrov
and what Azarenka and Robin Thicke I'm
gonna kick his ass today okay so you're
ready to win yes okay I'm not
competitive at all
[Music]
you know what's so amazing is that you
have already instilled that importance
of philanthropy in your kids I read that
you know you've shared that when one toy
Comes Your Way eight more get donated
and Willow likes being in charge of that
right they're so thoughtful about it
yeah but you know because you know if
you make the pile yourself of the toys
that you're going to give away all of a
sudden it'll be the toy that they want
to play with and they haven't thought
about it in five years
so yeah we do one toy in eight go out
and also Willow does all kinds of bake
stands and raises money for sloths wow
and she gave during coven when I gave my
money to Temple University Hospital in
Philadelphia she ran in her room and
thinks she had like 300 bucks from Tor
and she was like I want to give this to
the local hospital and then Jameson goes
well I want to give Willow all my money
I was like no that character is giving
though right oh no don't give her your
money
[Music]